is this the news that all of us Gators
have been waiting for
this is exciting
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
I'm not going to leave you in suspense
if you are a regular site tracker you'll
know that I have contacts that work in
and around MGM and now working around
Amazon you'll also know that Mark Fergus
and Hall ghost speak best name ever have
been developing a Bible a Content Bible
of what a new series or franchise of
Stargate would look like
you'll also know that several big
companies including Bad Robot and etc
etc have been pitching to Amazon to do
Stargate we recently found out thanks to
dial the gate that actually Mark Fergus
was approached by Amazon that during a
meeting following the success of the
expanse Amazon asked Mark Fergus what
would you like to do in the future and
he actually said Stargate
so uh you can tell me how you managed to
pull this one off well I'd say it was a
combination of things
my legal skills my eloquence
the indisputable logic of my arguments
and the bribe I offered color
don't forget to like subscribe and share
the video with all of your other Gator
friends also you go to scydashtrack.com
for brilliant Stargate related merch
just like this you can even buy socks
and anything else you want all of the
links are in the description so I'm not
going to leave you in suspense any
longer the big news is Mark Fergus looks
like he might have won the race his
production company penguin in a Parker
might actually be the company that is
going to produce new Stargate and again
if you are a regular sidetracker you'll
know the kind of people I speak to and
that they have been extremely reliable
in the past
we get paid for this right
[Music]
welcome back
it looks like they have begun the
negotiations for that and actually
initial contracts have been written up
now this is still pretty much early days
and it still could go massively sideways
but at the moment it's looking really
really promising this is the closest
we've ever gotten to get in Stargate
back so let me very quickly tell you
what this basically means now several
months ago Amazon start putting out a
request for any company that would like
to pitch for a new Stargate series it
was around this time that Mark Fergus
was during another meeting asked what he
would like to do and he as I say said
I'd love to do Stargate now I know Bad
Robot and several other production
companies this including the production
company that does the boys have pitched
four Stargate and what they are what
their idea would be for the new
franchise now Mark Focus looks like they
had the best pitch
from what I'm being told more than one
company was then asked to go a little
bit further and produce sort of some
initial artwork and things and what they
think the project would look like even
suggest what sort of actors they would
like to appear in it and even maybe
produce very early versions of a script
all of this was then reviewed looked at
and a decision was made and it looks
like that decision was to go with Mark
fergus's penguin in a Parker so to
clarify they've had the pitch meetings
they would have whittled it down
potentially they've had initial artworks
and some initial scripts done and the
winner was penguin in a Parker Mark
fergus's company
okay show us what you've got
star games
thank you
next
now again if you don't know much about
Mark Fergus and penguin and Parker these
were the guys that did much of the work
for the expanse Mark Fergus with his
partner Hawk ospi that do loads and
loads of projects together did much of
the development work for the expanse so
if you enjoyed the expanse they're
really the guys you need to thank they
took the original material and developed
it into a TV series that to me was one
of my favorite and most realistic sci-fi
shows that's been on the TV for a very
long time these guys are people that I
actually really trust to go with this
Stargate project now I am gutted still
that Brad Wright hasn't got this role
and then they didn't go with the script
that Brad Wright wrote or at least given
Brad Wright an opportunity to write
another one but if Brad Wright isn't
going to do it and I had to choose who
would I would go with Mark Ferguson Hawk
Osby if these guys are involved together
or separately I think they could
actually produce something really really
brilliant also remember that they
actually wrote a lot of the scripts for
the expanse so if you like the tone you
like the stories you liked the dialogue
in this series You're Gonna Love what
they do with Stargate so just really
really quickly to recap that we've got
the news we wanted this is the big one
all we're really waiting for now is the
official announcement the Rubber seal
and I'm still being told that is looking
like January so they're really pushing
forwards to get this announced by the
January 15th date when epics becomes MGM
plus they will use it as a way to really
get a load of clicks and a load of
interest because there is a massive
online community that are biting at the
bit for Stargate to return
if we if we've been building up towards
this for a long time we've been hearing
more and more rumors more and more
stories there's more and more articles
being released online and things and and
actually MGM Executives and Amazon
Executives have been dropping the
Stargate name every chance they get so
I'm not surprised this has happened but
I'm very excited and you know at times
I've even thought this wasn't going to
get to this point even at times I
thought this is not gonna happen but
really unless something disastrously
goes wrong now we will be getting
Stargate very very soon and let me just
say I am really sorry I can't say more
about where I got this information from
again this Source has told me something
in strict confidence if I did give you
more details his job would be at risk
but what I can tell you is that I am 100
confident that the information he's
giving me is accurate and this is the
chap as well that gave me the
information about Mark Ferguson the
first place that gave me the information
about Brad writing that how Amazon did
really like his script and reading has
given me the best information in and
around Stargate so I can put hand on my
heart promise you that this is really
good Intel let's just hope that
negotiations go smoothly and we get
something on our screen as quickly as
possible
but what will we get in our screens is
the next big question
but I'll wait that for another video so
get in the comments guys to tell me
exactly what you think about this news
how excited are you how nervous are you
that it could go all horribly wrong
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content and you want to
become a fully fledged side Trekker
please consider hitting the join Button
as always please stay safe it's coming
home
see you next time
[Music]